das ist das schloss brühl ein
weltkulturerbe
das ist alles rokoko das passt doch gut
zu deinem event
alle haben damals zusammen gearbeitet
deutsche und italienische und
französische architekten bildhauer maler
und stuckateure genau das sind doch die
die ganzen verzierungen machen aber
warum sind wir hier
das ist ein weltkulturerbe wie du schon
richtig gesagt hast das können wir nicht
bieten
das sollte doch auch gar nicht wir
machen eine führung durch das schloss
und danach gibt es einen empfang mit
catering in einem festzelt hier auf der
wiese
das ist doch alles viel zu teuer
du weißt doch gar nicht was das kostet
wir könnten doch erstmal einen kosten
einen kostenvoranschlag machen lassen
naja
gehst du bitte später noch so passt für
mich
ok
charlotte und nora schiefer sind
persönlich nicht zu sprechen
bitte lassen sie einfach eine nachricht
mama ganz weg bitte zurückrufen ich
brauchte ich jetzt also
weil sich ja
ja hallo reza du solltest dich bei lena
melden
hallo hier ist lothar schäfer ist meine
mutter bei dr jedem us
ich wollte das nicht es ist gestern
nacht einfach so passiert einfach so
tutu du musst das verstehen
lotte brauchte jemanden zum reden und
ich brauche auch jemanden zum reden aber
deswegen steige ich doch nicht sofort
mit dem erstbesten ins bett es war doch
auch nicht geplant
ich vermisse lena und irgendwie auch
nicht
es fühlt sich nicht so an als wären sie
und ich überhaupt noch zusammen
wir haben uns auseinandergelebt
du kannst du lena nichts davon sagen ich
muss erstmal selber damit klar
salatic hinter bist du ja hallo
und was sagt ob da jemals so ach naja er
will mich jetzt auf ein neues medikament
einstellen mag jetzt vielleicht besser
angelegt
dann drücke ich dir mal die daumen ja
auch dafür dass dr jemals sich
vielleicht an dich erinnert
naja die sagen du wär schon seit einiger
zeit nicht mehr da gewesen
und ein angeblicher rheumatologen auch
noch nie was von dir gehört
charlotte kind